mom hello welcome welcome hello how's it
going now you know how last time I
subjected you to Horrors on reddit for
[Music]
[Applause]
roars not yeah so that's
traumatic my mom has been traumatized
and she will never forgive me maybe not
so I've got something special for you
today that I think you're gonna like
instead of hate this is called - try not
to smile like right now yeah okay so
what we have here is a subreddit called
made me smile so the objective is we're
gonna look at these things and we are
not going to smile
give me definition of a nice smiling
smile smile is showing your teeth smile
is any upward motion yeah so as long as
I don't steal my teeth it's not smiling
what okay that's all right that'll
that'll be the limiter so as long as we
don't show our teeth it's not a smile
you ready yes okay three my face my face
is a mask of sorrow to death every day
of life I've seen it that happened every
day of life
listen if I laugh at what you say that's
very different from me smiling it what
this is not smiley no smiling mm-hmm
just crap every day everybody can do
that kind of stuff everybody can I can
do you could do that that's nothing
right yeah I believe you normal everyday
normal everyday stuff it's nothing to
smile
nothing to smile about this is a post
let me read it for you I have these two
neighbors and they're married and they
got to be like in their late 30s
and I'm making dinner and I look
the window and they're running around
outside in their pajamas and bare feet
with water pistols soaking each other
and laughing so loud it made me realize
I'm wasting so much time trying to make
relationships perfect when all that's
really needed is someone who will laugh
with me for the rest of my life okay
that's next okay that's not nice at all
my daughter got a Walmart gift card for
Christmas and she chose a new Diary of a
Wimpy Kid book instead of toys so it's
just a kid that chose a book over toys
and apparently that's smile worthy
nothing to smile about two out of
ordinary nothing to smile it's sad
really it's sad yes it's a kid not
living their child yes you hear that my
mom feels pity for you
this is says made my day I'm a miner my
son who is in third grade drew this in
art class for me today so it's like a
dad shining his light on the family
mm-hmm
anything anything to say about that I
rather look at you and smile you're dead
inside very dead no heart no soul I
exist in that puppies and Maki yeah okay
well how am I throw a curve ball because
here comes a puppy this one says I will
always love you
[Music]
no that's not cute they're cute no no no
smiling it's stupid actually it's two
animals fighting why would that be any
sort of entertaining no way this is a
portrait drawing I made for my grandma
unfortunately my grandpa passed away
last month so I wanted to surprise her
for Christmas oh that's nice
this kid made a portrait grandpa grandma
grandpa passed away
nice nice but I I'm not smiling not sad
really it's sad why would anyone smile
at this actually is kind of a really sad
true say so every time I look at the
picture reminding every day he's mean
she's mean that kids mean that kid mean
what kind of grandchild would do that to
their grandma so it says those poor
burglars well Kohli Culkin I feel bad
about all the burglars who never had the
confidence to rob a house on Christmas
thanks to me that's the kid who's in
home alone you're right there might be
somebody who really do robbed on
Christmas Day yes tipped all you
would-be robbers out there on Christmas
there's more gifts to rob or yours miss
what are you doing are you doing what
are you doing stupid has just been the
top of today let's look at the top of
the past month let's get to the really
good
it's oh it's gonna be good okay this
one's called the strength of humanity
mhm
sounds pretty impressive if anyone would
like 2018 to include some good news here
it is my six-year-old daughter who woke
up paralyzed from the waist down at
eight months who did many rounds of
chemo beat cancer and regained the use
of her legs has her first dance recital
tomorrow so sad happiness here this
one's a good father I had the pleasure
of sitting next to Hal on my flight back
home his daughter Pierce was our flight
attendant who had to work of Christmas
how decide we would spend the holiday
with her so he is flying on each of her
flights today and tomorrow around the
country to spend time with his daughter
for Christmas what a fantastic father
wish you both a very Merry Christmas
sounds like it costs a lot of money
mm-hmm sounds like it kind of offset all
the work that she did
that's not her moan is his motivation
this the father wanted to be there for
his daughter I know what why he's free
frakkin miles yeah that's only that's it
yeah he's not spending his own money
mm-hmm no way good ship he's cheap that
father's cheap next always remember
where you came from oh it's cool it's
the story of someone who came from KFC
to housekeeping to met a nursing nurse
and registered nurse you're a nurse
I I did that mm-hmm I worked as no seat
school so that's nice a weekend that's
relatable view and I become a RN so
there there are nice nice or is it
typical and everyone does this
you need to before market Bellaire what
did you do web buds yeah we all do that
you smell something to smell about
nothing to smile about nothing to smile
about or smell about not smiling
laughing no I'm laughing at myself from
very different okay right finally debt
free credit card paid off look at this
no debt I'm not good
something is Beach here I think that is
weird that it's absolutely zero on all
of these that is that is a little odd I
will admit that yeah yeah you just got a
bunch of them he's happy because the
pilot said oh I know human psychology
that was I made a psychology class hmm I
know he wants that clothes and I know
how they think
you know how those people think zero
zero violence because shopping yet
hasn't gone out shopping yet but will
after this post my face physically hurts
from smiling so much today I love
teaching you guys my professor who's
such a good soul mm-hmm well do I need a
smile about he's smiling why only thing
I can smile is his leg is kind of funky
just like you're late unnaturally is
that something to smile about no you're
right that's not it's a deformity mm sad
really
this guy this poor guy messed-up legs
okay same time I made this tie for my
dad when I was a first grade 11 years
later he wears it to my graduation hmm
chip
no time for shopping excuse excuse
excuse and he's proud of it
oh you should feel sad yeah that's real
sad sad what a cheap dad
ship that cheap penny-pinching that's it
yep you could have bought a special time
yes that said that's really sad very sad
man's best friend so your little Bobby
well Rex here has been going on and on
about you for the last 50 years what's
the point here
well it's like the dog died when 50
years ago yeah
and the dog's been in heaven or whatever
this whole time I've had a better life
than him you're right
he got mousse poodle right it's sad
really got the better life you just came
after 50 years well you could joke
earlier could've died earlier mmm it's
sad that he didn't die or sooner
yeah reporting a boy just ran up to the
live truck and said can you report my
smile yes we can Cameron give him a
credit someday you'll be famous would
that smile it's cute too it's sad really
really that's so sad he's just a Fame
hungry kid mm-hmm just trying to steal
the limelight anyway all right what's
this is a video
I'm not smarter you know I was looking
at the court I love that coach's smiling
at him that you are not the one actually
did you see the quality we're doing you
smile it's sad really look at the coach
his mom he's working harder than the
form of the guide the front is I think
that's a smile and I think we can end it
before we crush people's dreams more
then everything else was sad everything
what's that exploitative yes wanna be
famous wanna be famous it's ridiculous
what gets on the internet these days
mobile oh great yeah that's that you
hear that bubble that's sad that's real
sad well thank you everybody so much for
watching if you smiled down the comments
below let us know or don't because you
didn't smile either way thanks mom for
being here we got more videos that we're
gonna record soon less wholesome more
silly but you'll see them soon so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always we'll see you bye bye
[Laughter]
[Music]
you